in Pakistan the number of people killed
so far during the monsoon rain season
has risen to 76. most fatalities are in
the Northwest province of Punjab
torrential downpours triggered flooding
and landslides over the past two weeks
Kamal Haider 4 is their force in the
Punjabi provincial capital of lahorn of
course the rain made it might have
stopped Kamal but that doesn't mean the
crisis is over
absolutely flood warnings are still in
place as you mentioned those casualties
are because of exposed power lines
because of poor urban planning you of
course have been covering Pakistan and
know how poor the drainage system is in
the cities but the flood warning is very
much in place because this city was
founded by a heavy rain in 10 hours it
received almost six months of rain in
just 10 hours also the fact that every
time the monsoon hits and if there's
pressure on the Indian side particularly
in the Northern areas of India aware of
the encatchment areas of these rivers
are every time they come under stress
because of the heavy Monsoon the Indians
then have to release some of those
Waters from their water systems into the
Pakistani Rivers River Raleigh is
passing through Lahore and the Indians
are now releasing about 180 three
thousand hundred and eighty three
thousand sorry uh q6 of water into that
river which may cause a low flood
situation so no alarm there but the
situation indeed quite tense because of
the effects of climate change and the
fact that people now expect the meat
geological Department of course is
saying that they expect heavy downpour
which will cause more urban flooding and
perhaps even have an effect on the
farming areas in the Hinterlands thanks
very much Kamal obviously it's a
developing story that we're keeping an
eye on certainly over the next few weeks
as that Monsoon hits the region come
outside our senior correspondent to
Pakistan